on average Trump voters are less  cognitively sophisticated they are more  likely to believe untruths look at the  study they are more likely to be literal  Believers of some elements from the  Bible I don't see that in laugh like  that's not funny to me I want to solve  problems and one of the things that I've  said many times is when we have to argue  about  this is a shorthand dumb things  we aren't arguing about or debating or  working towards solving real and  complicated issues when we have 57 of  the Republican Party believing that the  election was literally stolen from Trump  by Biden and that Trump's the rightful  winner  and we have to you know fend off more  than 60 frivolous lawsuits in court  making that case and all of this  different stuff when we're fighting that  we're not actually fixing other problems